voici la solution provisoire pour les
habitants de grand rivière
ce camion citerne rempli de 23 mètres
cubes d'eau potable à l' usine la capote
aura la charge d'approvisionner les
avoirs de la commune rotation de 3 à peu
près par jour d'ici demain après midi
notre citerne de notre réservoir de
grandes bières sera totalement rempli et
à compter de demain
l'eau sera rétabli sur le territoire de
granby et nous n'aurons pas non plus à
nous inquiéter d'un problème de
turbidité de l'eau dans la mesure où je
fonctionne sans la rivière à comté de
zhouqu
cette proposition a été faite lors de la
réunion entre l'asm ds gap nord le
sous-préfet de trinité la mairie et les
habitants de grand rivière si dernier
excédé de ne plus avoir d'eau au robinet
depuis plusieurs semaines en bloquer
l'entrée de la ville ce matin après une
heure des changes la situation se
débloque
la population est satisfaite mais il
reste encore quelques questions sans
réponse je suis satisfaite life juste
attendre on attend et puis
la mobilisation devant reprendre et on
aura quand même de l'eau en fin de
soirée ou demain matin
bon une fois ya pas eu de langue de bois
c'est à dire on nous dit qu'on ne sait
pas pourquoi
la rivière est trouble jusqu'à
maintenant on nous affirmait que c'était
des émules et donc moi j'attends de voir
la modernisation de l'usiné de
distribution d'eau a également été
évoqué lors de cette réunion
aujourd'hui on a on a un outil en
interne du travail qui commence à être
un peu âgées et dont les limites
d'utilisation sont trop sont font pas
assez large en fait donc effectivement
dans la dans la discussion qu'on aura à
terme avec avec cap nord c'est de
pouvoir moderniser cette usine en
utilisant des filtres plus performant
avec un débit plus important et une
plage d'utilisation qui sera
effectivement plus grande et qui nous
permettra de pallier à ces problèmes de
tiab de turbidité
si la situation a été provisoirement
réglé aucune date d'un retour à la
normale n'est pour l'instant avancé par
la slps
car une partie de la solution finale
dépend aussi de dame nature qui comme
tout le monde le sait peut être
capricieuse